you don't say ce plaisir aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur oleg dou km une petite
aventure en 2d pixelisé on joue jamais à
ce genre de judas béthune aujourd'hui
voyais un début à tout voilà j'avais
envie de tester un billet sur start
c'est parti apparemment l'histoire ces
quatre personnes qui vendent week-end
sauf que ça se passe très mal
elle sort de zombies qui arrivait tout
bouclage du coup je ne comprends
absolument pas pourquoi dans une ville
sous la pluie à ok ça va sortir sous
forme d'épisodes et là c'est l'épisode 3
c'est parti on y va alors du coup faire
quoi vous amuser en fait c'est ça je
peux jeter dans l'eau par exemple de
jeter à huy parfait ah je vais jouer cet
homme auquel home bienvenue quoi ad on
peut tous se mettre nu oui c'est
fantastique car c'est drôle on connaît
direct la personnalité du joueur tu sais
le mec qui arrive ils verraient que mel
tout le monde lui avant même de
comprendre l'histoire
las un petit scooter je faire du scooter
oui et donc la tuer ou la tuer
il est vraiment vraiment flatteur faut
pas jeter mes potes avant même qu'ils
aient l'invasion de montres chelou mais
j'ai recommencé
ensuite on prend des biens ont les mois
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut boire des
bières nu au soleil ou là il concède
sévèrement bourg et moi je vais changer
de personnage moi j'aimerais bien faire
ça dans la vraie vie tu sais quand t'es
pas bien tu changes de corps voilà
revoir je peux pas passer à sa qui gère
non [ __ ]
ben voilà on a trouvé une lampe attend
la nuit tombe et là et ce à quoi sont
attaqués c'est ça y alors oui je ne sais
pas sur quoi y'a aucun mot syriens ou
juste 4 mec à poil quoi et quoi dans
l'eau est un oiseau là j'me bouge pas
dans votre [ __ ] y'a rien et c'est une
vulgaire car prix qui me fait mal quoi
je m'attendais à un zombie trop stylé
dans ta [ __ ] mais si elle pour
déverrouiller le passage en fait faut
nager jusqu'à tout à gauche pour prendre
cet arbre là y compris tout là haut il
faut pas y aller en scout dans l'eau
salée j'aimerais plus vite
je suis très heureux bon là j'ai déjà
deux morts dans la nuit alors qu'il y
avait juste absolument rien qui
m'attaquaient quoi par une carpe au
maire pour ckoi s'est enfui s cachait
derrière l'arbre isabelle non mais je
peux plus bouger alors jma infi non
mélange est en surpoids les tétons à
l'air comme ça en regardant à son biseau
défi on essaye fla non je suis entré
dans la maison non mais j'ai fait une
partie de merde à jadriya un cheval tout
je suis sûr qu'on peut passer de l'autre
côté ce truc c'est obligé oui soir
attention à la carte u2 haye tant pis
aino il est mort je mette une
éclaireuses sur le butin de râteaux jeu
mais tu n'es clos sur le toit et on va
passer la nuit comme ça mon gars ok ok
il ya une tyrolienne mec les tyroliennes
moi je meurs pas ce que je t'ai vu sur
un râteau téléphone qui marche pas
pourquoi je me vois quelque chose dans
y'a rien on est d'accord et absolument
rien et vous voulez quelque chose vous
taisez c'est comme ça que ça marche et
c'est ok je suis un dictateur du jeu bon
paul qui sort ne s'oublie d'affaires
avec les crues les créent les québec
l'éclaireur du front voilà un hâle est
immense coup tu prends ton scoot n'etai
aucun monstre à l'horizon
non et ça n'a même pas casser les
caisses à 6 à marcher mon gars il est
mort ça devenait un [ __ ] double il
faut je m'équipe tu m'as super jeu pas
que transforme en zombie biatch beaucoup
là bas y'a quoi les petites maisons avec
de l'essence dedans annoncé générateur
d'électricité peut-être pas que je
referme toi la balle à quoi alors auriez
h et où il ya du stuff la voiture se met
nu en plus donc c'est vraiment bien on
alla hll et où elle allait emmener là
mais l'unijambiste maintenant elles
servent plus à rien quoi
ouais g2l m ok on va faire un truc là
pour défendre juste là temps on va
pouvoir les défoncer vous savez qu'on
met un coup de hache dans un bidon
d'essence ça n'explose pas il nous reste
qu il nous reste une union bus quoi se
passe quoi là et les bruits au fait
qu'ils n'ont plus la main à tant de
temps déjà on va lui apprendre la vie
parce que je suis gens disent que je
suis
[Musique]
toi ton chien tes amis est mort game
over
à gauche on montre qu'on se retourne
devant cet homme en pyjama dans 20
minutes où l'accueille comme il se doit
oh non you i will où je l'étais fond
c'est bien la tient pitch j'éprouve h 12
non attendez tcc 4 il n'en restera qu'un
il met parfaitement s'écoule à son poids
réel vient la direccte vient cause
alors c'est quoi fera plus jamais des
jeux pixelisé voilà l'aide aux échecs
il va arriver c'est sûr il va arriver
attendait tenez vous prêts attention vos
âmes on signale t il apparaît de manière
aléatoire quoi tu alors il m'a agressé
direct là il est pas là il faire le
guet-apens et le flair je pensais qu'on
allait pouvoir réparer ça avec des
outils là peut-être lui avec le marteau
oh oui comme ça on peut aller là-haut et
on peut se casser une [ __ ] de gens oui
oui et là on a axé là haut je sais pas
ce que ja mais à mon avis mais voilà
comment on faire ça sans perdra mais on
faisait ça ça remonte et on perdait pas
un mec au début de la game on commence à
bien découvrir le jeu je l'entends je
l'entends demeurer gauche aillent là
depuis voilà il a alors là mais non il
est beau lot il et leïla leïla est et
qui hélas mon gars il va péter dans une
explosion bien là raphaëlle tervel
[ __ ] il prend les escaliers je
voudrais parler quoi mais calmes et
qu'elle fdp
j'aurai ta peau on est de retour sur les
lieux cabine
voilà quand j'en mets partout mais que
ça à faire une explosion nucléaire
auquel arrive il arrive bientôt le père
noël arrive tâche ou une tension là il
est pas loin et si je rentrais sur plein
de fois nul homme je me met nu comme ça
sert à mentir à son temps de réflexion
n'hésitera il va il va prendre le
scooter mon gars c'est notre put un
dernier recours il a regardé la chute
dans l'eau actuellement il peut pas
débuter mais si je la tire dans le piège
oh mon dieu mon dieu dieu soit loué
brand of rock band the same as monaco
entre les banques est de plus que tu
t'en rue à tandil ou cacher vos cartes
ces photos oe crash coûtera temps tient
fils de petits objets mis son masque
j'ai mis sur mass tu fais quoi
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'en fais pas stéphanie toi bien se
passer ou le petit [ __ ] non watts
qu'elle est faite elle fait quoi le
ferry hôpital en train de nager de plus
en plus patent fait caca chien fin elle
a en fait ça peut être un leurre donc là
il ya lui et lui il a juste une là je
peux le but et je peux le but et sans l
aval buts et memex et d'une dureté c'est
incroyable mais le meilleur essai de ma
vie il y en a quatre missions oxis j'ai
plus le scooter j'ai pu de bidons
d'essence ggg qu'un couteau et les
bières quoi bien c'est une bière et tout
est résolu un nom en bois pas remarquons
macro mais y'a pas un truc cachait dans
ses toilettes là je crois qu'ils aient
la toilette est alléchante sa facette
vidéo sur les tubes gaby [ __ ] au début
je ne comprenais pas le sens du jeu et
en fait c'est juste survivre survivre
survivre
bref on est gentil avancée des données
ce n'est pas laid mais ça vous a plu
si vous voulez un deuxième épisode je
fermerai ce jeu jusqu'à ce que je les
pose sur fait une vidéo dessus
tam est ce que c'est dur sabine et
stéphanie la vidéo ça va plus on s'est
donc trouvée dans une prochaine merci
d'avoir regardé j'espère que ce style de
jeu vous plaît broder vie me plaisait
pas puis ensuite il me plaisait bien
plus plus qu à un moment où alors c'est
fermer la gueule ça va quoi personne
regarder être chaude pisse
[Musique]
moi c'est quoi ça qui est attaquée at on
dit au katana mika m'a attaqueront là
dessus où est la 2 buts 1 contacté
groupe gay et je me sens impuissant